A couple of days ago, I received
this email from
Google Analytics.
It's an intelligence alert
notifying me that the page
loading time for mobile visitors
to my site has an
unusual spike.
And this is a feature of Google
Analytics, that I don't
think many people know about.
And, in fact, you can use
it to monitor your web
performance metrics, which
is really cool.
So I figured I'd give you
guys a quick overview.
So, first of all, let's start
at the beginning.
That's always a good
place to start.
We're looking at Google
Analytics, so
we just logged in.
This is your regular report.
This is specific to my site,
so this is [INAUDIBLE]
dot com.
So let's find intelligence
reports.
For that, you need to click into
home, and you have this
section here called Intelligence
Events, so let's
go to that overview, and what
you'll see here is that Google
Analytics creates a number of
automatic alerts for things
like number of page views, of
visits, bounce rates, and a
few other things.
You can see that there are some
alerts that are firing
here already.
But the real power of this
functionality here is that you
can actually customize
it to any metric
within Google Analytics.
And as you may know, Google
Analytics tracks web
performance metrics through
navigation timing, which means
that we can also set up alerts
and get notifications for
things like page loading times,
response times, DNS,
and many other things.
So in fact, that's exactly
what I did.
That's why I got that alert.
So I have a couple of custom
alerts set up in my account.
One is called--
One is specifically tracking
mobile and the other one is
just a generic page loading
time difference.
So these are actual alerts that
have fired over the past
couple of days.
So let's take a look
at one of them.
We have this PLT, stands for
page load time, so I'm going
to click on the details
section for
this guy right here.
And what you can see here
is the actual alert.
So this graph here shows you
the average page load time.
It's across all of my visitors
for all of my pages, and on
November 23, there's little kind
of bump right here, and
this actually triggered
an alert.
And the best part about Google
Analytics is not that it just
detected that there's this
little bump here, but it
actually tries to infer as to
what are the contributors to
this bump right here.
And what it figured out was that
the major contributors
are likely from India,
from city of Chennai.
And, in fact, it's looking at
the metrics for those segments
and it's saying, look, on
average, same day in the
previous week, the page load
time was about 10 seconds, for
whatever reason it's
30 seconds.
That's not good.
For this specific city, the
page load time spiked from
seven to 90 seconds.
That's terrible.
Something is terribly
wrong there.
So not only that, but you can
also click on these things
right here, it will reload the
graph and show you the page
load time for this
specific segment.
So now we're looking at India,
and as you can see the page
load time is semi-reasonable,
six, seven seconds, but ever
once in a while we get these
spikes, 25 seconds, 25, and in
this case, 32 seconds.
So there's something systematic
going wrong here,
and I don't know exactly
what it is.
I need to track it down.
We can also drill into the
specific cities and look at
the same graph.
And, in fact, you can see that
this is a second occurrence of
the same event.
So this happened earlier and
I didn't catch this.
So this is where having an alert
is very, very useful.
First, you'll know
that something
anomalous has happened.
I wouldn't have detected this
otherwise, and two, it can
actually help you figure
out what is the
cause of the problem.
So with that, let's actually
take a look at how you would
go about setting up one of
these custom alerts.
So let's close that,
and we can go into
manage custom alerts.
Create an alert.
And let's create an alert, I
don't know, let's track Japan.
Actually, you know what?
We're going to look
at all traffic,
we're looking for country.
So we're going to look at
country and territory, matches
exactly, Japan.
That's what we want.
And so here we're defining what
segment of the traffic
that we want this alert
to apply to.
Then we need to specify the
actual metric, which is going
to be used to track the alert.
So in this case, we actually
have a number of navigation
time metrics that we're tracking
Google Analytics.
So we can look at things like
response time, so this is your
server response.
So, for whatever reason, if your
server starts responding
slowly to specific visitors,
you can flag that here.
I'm going to look at
page load time.
So this is the average page load
time, and I'm going to
trigger this if it increases
by more than,
let's say, 30% on--
you can do on a previous day,
previous year, or previous
week, so in my earlier alert, I
just used the previous week,
but let's create this
one right here.
So that's it.
We can save the alert and
Google Analytics will
automatically monitor
and notify you.
And you can apply this against
multiple profiles, here I'm
just specifying one site.
You can specify the period as
well, so this is for how far
back should the alerts look at
to detect these anomalies?
So it should be a day, a week,
or perhaps, even a month.
So that's a very quick
introduction, but there's
actually much, much more.
And to understand the power of
what this gives you, you
really have to familiarize
yourself with advanced
segments of Google Analytics.
So let's cancel out of this, and
let's head back into our
standard reports.
And let's actually look at the
site speed reports, which is
using navigation timing
to track all
the performance data.
So here's our little
spike that we
were looking at earlier.
And let's say, we want to
compare this against desktop
or maybe mobile traffic.
So you can click on bad segments
and Google Analytics
gives you, by default,
a number of segments.
So mobile is one, and I can
compare this to, let's say,
all visits.
Let's hit Apply.
And it will provide us with two
segments, so now you can
see that the orange line here is
the all visits and the blue
line is the mobile traffic.
So mobile's doing pretty well.
There's two spikes, but then
look at this, the desktop or
the averages for all of my
visits are fine, but mobile
specifically, is
what's spiking.
So this already gives me a way
to figure out, is it mobile
visitors or somebody else that's
contributing to this
spike right here.
But that's kind of cool, but
the real power in the story
here is the fact they can define
your own segments.
So let's do exactly that.
We'll create a new segment,
and we can, once again, we
have access to all the Google
Analytics variables, so we can
say continents.
Let's look at Asia.
We can add an or statement so we
can look at Asia or Europe.
Let's add another one,
so continent again.
Let's see, or let's do North
America perhaps.
Not coming up right now.
Well, you can define multiple
continents or any multiple
metrics, and you can also end,
so there's an or statement and
an end statement.
So we can filter down the
specific segment that we're
looking for.
So let's add an end
statement in here.
So you can look at the
hundreds of different
variables that are in here, and
you have access both to
the dimensions and individual
metrics.
So there's things like if you
have defined goals or revenue
conversions, you can actually
track that here.
So you can say, look, I'm
concerned about visitors that
come from Asia that are
purchasing stuff on my site.
But you also have all of the
page loading time metrics and
all the rest.
So lots and lots of
flexibility here.
And the cool part is once you
define the segment, so I'll
show you a couple of segments
that I defined previously.
For example, I have visitors
from Japan that are coming on
a desktop browser.
And if I apply that,
that's what we're
looking at are here.
Now, now that we've defined the
segment, we can actually
head back into Home,
Intelligence Events, and when
we're defining a new custom
alert, now you
can use this segment.
So instead of just saying all
traffic, you have this tab
here called custom segments.
You can open this up, and you
have all of the segments that
you defined previously.
So, for example, visitors
from San Francisco
coming on mobile phone.
That's something that I've
defined specifically for my
site, but you could have created
a different segment,
which is related to registered
users that have purchased
something on your site in the
last 30 days, for example.
And that you want an alert if
one of those users' page load
time is greater than 10 seconds,
and that's it.
You save this alert, and you
would get, if something bad
happens, you would get
an alert like this.
You can go into Google Analytics
and figure out
what's going on, which
is pretty awesome.